is the EU playing into the hands of
people smugglers by accepting to
relocate 160,000 asylum seekers who
entered the EU illegally some MPs are
now afraid that the institutions are
sending the wrong message subsequently I
saw in DMV Adi glancing of harmony
mamiya mention anna-marie hope Davi so
it was me Tamia and so Trayton it's when
Bianca Vigo shafin ville by not
providing any legal and safe and cheese
for Refugees we're actually supporting
the smugglers the only ones who are
benefiting from all offences from all
the walls at the outer borders the only
people profit from it are the smugglers
because refugees have no other way to
get into Europe to ask for asylum apart
from trusting those smugglers the EU
allocated 1 billion euros to UN agencies
running camps in non-eu countries
although not all member states were in
favor of harboring people fleeing from
war in Syria and Iraq it seems everyone
agrees that reinforcing he use external
borders is of the utmost importance
housing grants and secure intezar oppa
unda currency control it via of this
incontinent come on via mr up give Assad
must work if you'd wear out my
technician maznah men pillow Spinato
marie ago is me audio tuto choice
symbology Adela incapacitated is all
very problemi problem is resolved 10 in
modo positivo more support is being
planned trees in the upcoming weeks to
help ongoing operations on the ground